one of my favorite ways to close someone  is to just say whatever thing they said  they're struggling with that they're not  sure about you just say hey in a  hypothetical world where that didn't  exist would you say yes and whatever it  is if that thing doesn't exist and they  say sure then you literally now have  only one thing you need to solve to get  the sale right so if you're tired of  having people give you obstacle after  obstacle after obstacle you just say hey  if you had the time would you do it if  they say yes and it's like cool let's  figure out how to get you the time right  and then you can solve one problem and  make the deal the same thing is hey if  your wife were on board would you do it  okay cool then what would we need to do  to figure out so she wouldn't be worried  about it right so whatever the thing is  you just say hey in a hypothetic world  that didn't exist would you do it cool  and then you can close the one isolated  variable to get the deal done